mélanie joly mines et des affaires
étrangères est avec nous bonsoir madame
joly
quelle journée pour pour le monde
vraiment triste
vous comment vous avez d'abord avant
d'aller dans les sanctions et l'utilité
ou pas des sanctions comment vous avez
vécu à la nuit dernière comme on le
voyait venir j'étais convaincu comme
d'autres comme les américains qui à
l'arrivée mais c'est sûr qu'on avait de
renseignement qui démontrait justement
que les bombardements allaient commencer
qu'ils allaient commencer vers 10 heures
le soir et c'est à peu près au moment où
ils ont commencé et j'ai été en contact
par la suite est entendu avec ma sous
ministre au ministère mais surtout aussi
avec notre ambassadrice sur place et
vous voyez depuis quelques temps déjà on
avait de l'information comme quoi qui
elle pouvait être une cible et donc
j'avais pris la décision avec mon équipe
de bouger nos effectifs de l'ambassade
de kiev faire la vive qui était beaucoup
plus à l'ouest plus proche de la
frontière avec la pologne est donc au
milieu de la nuit nuit j'ai eu
l'occasion de reparler encore à notre
ambassadrice la délégation canadienne au
grand complet soutenait aussi la
délégation de la suède qui avaient
besoin dead et donc ensemble
ce suite à l'autorisation de mon équipe
et moi ils ont décidé de quitter la vive
pour se rendre en toute sécurité
d'un autre côté en pôle emploi et pour
les ressortissants canadiens qui sont
toujours en ukraine qu est-ce qui lui
vont tenter de sortir par la route donc
comme plusieurs jours oui bien entendu
l'objectif c'est vraiment si vous
connaissez 6 de la famille des amis en
ukraine présentement s'il vous plaît
allez sur le site web d'affaires mondial
canada se remet médias sociaux vous
allez avoir toute l'information et
aimait bien entendu si à des
bombardements on vous demande d'aller à
un endroit sécuritaire et bien entendu
d'être capable de quitter le pays à
partir du moment où justement ce sera
plus sécuritaire mais pour l'instant on
a aussi les effectifs dans tous les
quatre pays limitrophes on a fait des
dégâts j'ai pris des ententes mon équipe
et moi avons pris des ententes avec la
hongrie avec la pologne avec la
slovaquie
également avec la roumanie et j'ai eu
des bons pour parler aussi avec la
moldavie donc baser là dessus on sait
qu'on peut avoir certainement de lettres
de l'autre côté de la frontière
ukrainienne je le dis pour ceux qui ne
le savent pas encore mais la communauté
ukrainienne canadienne est la plus
grande à l'extérieur de l'ukraine bien
sûr il ya 1,3 million de canadiens
d'origine ukrainienne au pays madame
joly je vous montre un tableau ne s'est
pas toutes les mesures et c'est de
certaines sont très complexes mais ce
qui est annoncé par le canada soixante
deux individus et entités russes se
viser interdit d'acheter la des truffes
interdit de transiger avec deux grandes
banques et l'interdiction d'exporter en
russie est-ce que c'est suffisant
beaucoup de voix on dit ça n'est pas
suffisant ce que c'est suffisant mais ce
que je rajouterais votre tableau que
malheureusement je ne vois pas mais ce
sont toutes les grandes banques russes
qui sont affectés par nos sanctions se
sont également oui une soixantaine
d'individus metz inclut également le
ministre des finances de la russie le
ministre de la justice de la russie est
également le ministre de la défense de
vladimir poutine donc est également nous
faisons en sorte de cancel et d'annuler
tous les permis d'exportation de biens
qui sont importants pour la russie qui
provient du canada notamment dans le
domaine de l'aérospatiale dans le
domaine des technologies de
l'information également dans le domaine
des minéraux alors notre objectif c'est
vraiment avec nos alliés de d'affaiblir
et de déstabiliser le régime poutine
étant donné ce qu'il ce qu'il fait lui
même et son équipe à à l'écran les
menaces de sanctions avaient été
télégraphié avait été dit et ça ne l'a
pas empêché donc ça fera quoi là mais
vous savez c'est sûr que le but c'est
d'être unis l'ouest au complet vous
l'avez mentionné en début d'un temps
d'intervention où vous avez mentionné
que toutes les capitales du monde avait
réagi aujourd'hui toutes les capitales
de l'occident mais c'est exactement ce
qu'on fait le but c'est que les
personnes autour de poutine sa garde
rapprochée soit affectée par justement
là la réponse de l'ouest que les russes
et l'économie russe soit affaibli et on
pense que bien entendu ça va pouvoir
déstabiliser poutine et ça va faire en
sorte d'affecter directement
sa cote de popularité et son appui
auprès de la population
on sait que des mouvements d'opposition
en russie on c'est exact a également que
ces mouvements d'opposition sont très
souvent non seulement affaibli mais
anéantie et donc plus on fait en sorte
de mettre de la pression sur le régime
russe plus on est capable d'arriver à
nos fins bon ben là dessus de questions
sur la durée parce que l'europe a besoin
du gaz russe aux besoins du de l'énergie
russe l'on a gelé le le gazoduc pour
l'instant l'optique devrait passer par
kiki parce qu'ils étaient construits
vous n'ayez est ce que votre ennemi
finalement c'est pas le tas et avec le
temps héros des brèches dans la
communauté internationale qu'il a
aujourd'hui bien sûr est sous le choc
non vous savez quoi le prix d'une guerre
est beaucoup plus grand pour la
communauté des affaires au niveau
international que le prix des sanctions
donc ça on a déjà eu ces conversations
laonnois en tant que ministre des
affaires étrangères est certainement le
premier ministre hugo avec avec ses
homologues premier point un deuxième
point on va faire en sorte de mettre
autant de pression possible et dans les
prochains jours les sanctions d'autres
sanctions va être ajouté aujourd'hui
c'est un bon départ le canada a un des
plus importants ensembles de sanction de
du g7 mais l'objectif c'est de rajouter
d'autres moyens d'autres sanctions pour
faire en sorte de maintenir la pression
il y avait cette idée de les bloquer du
réseau swift qui le réseau bancaire la
messagerie bancaire ça suscitait plus là
dedans tebbane ne peuvent plus faire
affaire avec personne ils ont plus de
pourquoi on n'est pas allés jusque là
vous savez comme j'ai dit encore
plusieurs options sur la table
le problème est aujourd'hui une
rencontre g7 et une rencontre de l'otan
également j'aurai une rencontre du g7 au
niveau des ministres des affaires
étrangères sous peu alors on continue de
travailler ensemble on sait très bien
que au fur et à mesure qu'il ya des vies
humaines qui sont perdus qu'il ya des
bombardements qui continue à travers
l'ukraine que l'on a cette
responsabilité morale et voire
historique d'agir et c'est exactement ce
qu'on fait aujourd'hui en terminant
madame joly est ce que le canada va
accueillir vont ouvrir ses bras va
faciliter l'arrivée d'ukrainiens qui
voudraient fuir très certainement en
planifiant le tout on savait qu'il peut
avoir des centaines de milliers de
personnes qui allaient se
réfugier vers les frontières à des pays
autour de l'ukraine qui font très
souvent partie de l'union européenne
alors c'est pourquoi on avait fait en
sorte de faire des ententes avec ces
pays là mais aussi on va jouer on va
jouer notre rôle on va faire notre part
parce que c'est important mélanie joly
mais les affaires étrangères merci
beaucoup de nous avoir parlé au revoir
au revoir